okay so uh the other day we covered
rudy giuliani donald trump's i guess
former personal lawyer had his home
and his office raided uh this is in
connection with an investigation into
whether rudy giuliani has committed
crimes related to
lobbying and ukraine of course he
says it's all bogus and his son came out
and gave a defiant
principled but confused speech about the
entire thing
um and then rudy giuliani hit the
interview circuit and we're going to
review an interview he did last night
with tucker carlson on fox news
everything about this interview is
completely off the rails and maybe the
funniest thing is that
rudy is so obsessed with hunter biden
that at one point in the interview rudy
refers to tucker
as hunter and tucker just does like the
confused face
everything about this is wild so let's
get right into it we'll do it a little
differently than normal
i'm going to play these clips and we're
going to go through it let's jump right
in the agents seemed
somewhat apologetic i might say they
were very very professional and very
gentlemanly
right the only time they got perturbed
is at the end of the surge
when they had taken about i'd say seven
or eight electronic items of mine which
is what they took
and and by the way i don't you know
maybe i don't understand
being a high-profile attorney or
whatever
uh i know people who have you know a
desktop computer and a laptop
and maybe they have two phones like a a
personal phone and a work phone
why is it so common that when they do
these
searches or surges as rudy called it
eight laptops and mobile phones or i
mean i i don't i just maybe i'm just not
in this space and i don't understand why
someone would have
that number of devices you know even
here it's like i've got my studio
computer and my personal computer and my
laptop
and then i have my one phone like eight
eight device anyway okay let's continue
someone else's i uh they weren't taking
the three hard drives which of course
are electronic devices they just mimic
the the computer
i said well don't you want these and
they said what are they i said
those are hunter biden's hard drives and
they said no no no
no no i said are you sure you don't want
that i mean
the warrant required them to take it and
they said
and i one last time i said yeah don't
you think you should take it to comp
and they said no rudy desperate that
they
investigate hunter even if it's through
a raid uh in connection with suspicion
of
rudy having committed uh i mean it's
just it's it's wild
now uh hunter biden's hard drives
fall within the scope of the subpoena
subpoena requires them to take all
electronics
but they decided to leave that behind
and they also
were completely content to rely on my
word
that these were hunter biden's hard
drives i mean they could have been
donald trump's they could have been
vladimir putin's
they could have been anybody's but they
relied on me
the man who had to be raided in the
morning
because look at tucker's face the entire
time by the way
destroy the evidence i've known about
this for two years uh tucker
i could have destroyed the evidence we
now here's a year i don't
destroy the evidence because the
evidence is exculpatory yeah so this is
this is one of the things i mentioned in
our coverage which is
i know that the fbi can recover things
you might think you've deleted
uh but is that is that not a concern um
and it just gets even crazier okay let's
let's continue
um now with with the next clip here uh
just an
incredible incredible interview oh and
that is not actually okay sorry no
here's the next uh here's the next clip
and here is where um rudy accidentally
calls tucker
hunter because he's been just obsessed
with him especially
i want to make that point also hunter i
am a lawyer
who has prosecuted a lot more serious
cases
that have been prosecuted yeah uh listen
uh
hunter i'm really a serious lawyer here
and you should be taking this very
seriously all right we've got a couple
more clips here to look
at uh this is rudy giuliani i guess it's
sort of like with matt gates
where matt gates the accusations came
out about matt gates a few weeks ago
when we were on our vacation and then
matt gates went on tucker's show and
actually
seemed guiltier than ever and raised new
questions about what he may or may not
he
at that point remember when matt gates
went on tucker's show
he hadn't yet been even accused of
paying anybody for sex never mind minors
and he goes on and he says tucker i've
never paid anyone for sex well
that's a whole new avenue of
investigation now okay let's let's look
here
bro being dismissed and it's stopping
this is no longer a free
we might as well be in you know east
berlin before the warfare
right this is this is tactics only known
in a dictatorship
where you you seize a lawyer's records
right in the middle of his
representation of his client
uh i mean you should be prosecuted and
just barred for that
so first of speaking of disbarred rudy
should be disbarred number one
is he saying he's still representing
donald trump because that would be news
but here's the really important thing
rudy wants to frame this as the timing
of this raid is because joe biden
is somehow involved joe biden is sicking
people on rudy giuliani
we know because of the new york times
report that
this raid would have happened when trump
was president because the justice
department was already looking into rudy
giuliani
but trump appointed loyalists in the
justice department
blocked the search warrant so the reason
this is happening now is not because
bain ordered it
the reason this is happening now is
because the obstruction
from trump loyalists during trump's
presidency
has ended there is no reason whatsoever
to think
that this has anything to do uh with joe
biden okay one more clip here this is
funny also
so not only does rudy refer to tucker as
hunter because he's so obsessed
rudy does this i'm sorry now i'm doing
it uh
tucker does this entire interview with
rudy
about all sorts of different things and
the first thing he mentions when the
interview is done
is also hunter biden take a look that i
served honorably and well
it's shocking i hope you'll come back i
have a feeling we're going to be hearing
a lot about
i will story former mayor rudy giuliani
thank you
so hunter biden lobby is the vice
president of the united states
oh wow what a blockbuster tucker so a
completely
off the rails interview it looks where
every time rudy speaks it looks worse
when his son spoke it looked worse
now that rudy is speaking it looks worse
when rudy's lawyer put out a statement
it looks worse
and by monday who on earth knows what
this situation is going to look like
we're going to continue covering it now
i'm already getting emails from people
saying david
that people people come to me and they
say sir do you think rudy is going to go
to prison
no i don't no i don't and i know every
time you know when i said there's no way
trump's going to prison and people got
mad and said david
you saying it is part of why trump won't
go no no me saying it has nothing to do
with it
i don't think there's any way in hell
that rudy giuliani goes to prison
i think even if rudy were to be charged
and even if rudy were to be found guilty
instead of
striking some kind of deal um as a 76
year old by the time that happened 77
78 i think that the universe we're
talking about which includes rudy
giuliani's
level of power and his age and the
crimes that are even sort of like being
talked about here
um i think in the even even a guilty
scenario
it's some kind of probation or suspended
sentence or whatever the case may be let
me know if you disagree with that piece
and we will keep following it